Yeah. So what other animals
are you looking for? A lot.
Like we were talking about primates.
I'm going to Borneo to look for
an animal called the millers,
grizzled nine gear to a type
of monkey. Um, I just got back,
I was looking for an extinct Cayman
in the Amazon think Cayman. Yeah.
What's the difference between that
and the Cayman's that you see?
A just a different species. You know,
just like there's many types of crocodile.
There's nine types of Cayman, you
know, you have salt, water, crocodiles.
Now Crocodiles, same
thing with Cayman. Um,
and I was looking for one with a
very weird morphological variants.
It looks very, very different
to any other, um, what's,
what's different about it?
It's got a very elongated snout.
Um, if you've ever seen a gharial,
if you know what that is, a type of
crocodile with this long crazy knows.
It's like the alligator family that
came and family version of that,
this really long, skinny face, super
light, super yellow coloration,
just very different.
Last time one was seen was 52 years ago
and then they had one in a zoo that died
in the 80s. And nobody's found one since.
Um, so just really cool. And so yeah,
the list goes on. You know, I,
last year I did leopards and I did wolves
in Newfoundland and a bunch of really
interesting stuff. So it's fun, man.
You love it. You should come with,
talk to animal planner. Scared. I'm
such a pussy. Um, what about uh,
giants loss?
What are your feelings on those?
So I've had probably three
years of research into this,
into giant slots because,
uh, Matt Nannup poor agree,
I believe is how it's said.
It's the South American name
for giant slots. There's,
I don't want to give away too much
info before I get to do a chance,
a chance at looking for it. But after
all the research I've compiled, there is,
in my opinion,
one location on earth.
It's in high Peru where nobody goes.
It's a bowl of mountains impenetrable.
The only way in is a helicopter in the
center to me that that ball is going to
be like a primordial Eden.
All of the cultures surrounding it
have old stories of giant slots.
They all have different names for it,
but they all have these stories
of these giant slots. Right.
They were all hunted to
extinction, however they've
handed down these traditions.
But nobody except for,
you know,
a tiny handful of like far out tribal
people have ever really got into this
impenetrable ball. And I think if
they're anywhere they're in there. Wow.
I saw a documentary once about this
scientist that was essentially risking his
reputation, trying to find a giant sloths
somewhere that maybe in the Amazon,
some somewhere, probably Peruvian Amazon.
That's where I'm thinking too. And uh, he,
he kept talking to people that had seen
it and he never could get ahold of it,
but he had been there for
years. Crazy though. Like why,
what if you're a little Amazonian village
or you don't read, you don't have TV.
There's no reason to make up
scientific, you know, science fiction.
Why say you've seen it cause you like
to fuck with white people. It could be
like get the stringy hair
dinosaurs.
Fucking five. Yeah. You
know, you're walking,
you're exhausted. Covered with mosquito
bites. He's like any day now. Yeah.
Just over the hill. He's just gonna
wait for you to fucking rot out.
That'd be a mean man. That's a meme
guy. Do you want to log all right buddy.
Pat You on the back. This is the last
spot for you. And I'll be taking,
I'll take your binoculars
and yeah. Um, I mean, yeah,
there's no reason for them to lie,
but that doesn't,
that's like the thing that people say
about everything. Why would she lie? Well,
I don't know. People lie for a bunch
of weird reasons. People are crazy.
They shit up. True. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
to me it's like you have to
take an eyewitness report
of an extinct creature or
a zoo crypto creature with a grain of
salt, but you still have to take it.
Do you know what I mean? You still
have to bank it and consider it. Yeah.
And so that's, that's kind of the
way I go. I, I always talk to people,
but then I come up with, I do the biology
right, I track, I put the cameras out,
I bait,
I sent,
I do all of that stuff to try and get
evidence of my own because just going with
eyewitness reports is,
like you say, it's nothing.
Is there ever been any eyewitness
reports that are just too,
too ridiculous where you're like, oh,
for sure. Like what? Oh man, loads.
I mean like talking about
the thylacine for instance,
there was a guy that we met there who's
like, yeah, their styles seen everywhere.
They run around with the black cats and
were like, what? And he's like, yeah,
there's black panthers too.
They like hang out together.
There's an Australian exactly that. I
made the same face you did. So I'm like,
okay, tell me more. And he's
like, yeah, you know, they
like to hang out over there.
They're behind the trash heap. They
jump around with Black Panthers. Oh,
they're just fucking with
it. And I'm like, well that's
the thing. I'm like, you're,
you're just, you're either crazy or
you're completely fucking with me.
And I'm not sure which one it is because
your eyes are telling me crazy. Yeah.
Well, I mean, how many different
pockets in the world are there?
Like that basin that you said you got
to get helicoptered into? There's a few.
There's a few. Yeah, you'd be
surprised because you know, we're here,
we're in a city,
we're so used to our modern conveniences,
but there are totally untouched
pieces of the world still. Well,
do you know David Cho, the artist? I
don't. He um, he went to the Congo,
I think it was the Congo
to look for a dinosaur. No,
it was a really early vice piece back
when vice was first starting out.
And David is one of the more
eccentric people that I know.
He's a multimillionaire.
He made a shit load of money gambling.
And also he made a shit load of money
because he was it Facebook painted,
painted Facebook. What does that
mean? Like the wall? Yeah. The inside,
they hired him to paint,
like do these murals and they gave him
stock and that stock wound up being worth
hundreds of millions of dollars.
And so now he's just this freaky,
super talented artists who
is just doing weird shit.
And one of the things they did was like,
hey man,
you want to go look for a dinosaur? He's
like, fuck yeah, I'll go, absolutely.
Why wouldn't you? You know?
But there's this video of him,
I want to say he was like 25 at the time
too. I think he was pretty young. Yeah.
Look at them there.
Oh yeah.
So he's in the jungle in search
of a fucking dinosaur because,
and it was one of those things where the,
the locals were saying, Hey, there's,
there's a dinosaur in the Congo. Right.
Which doesn't totally make sense,
but it, but, but who knows, right.
Why not investigate it kind of thing.
I mean,
how big of an area would there have to
be for there to be a species that we are
not aware of? Like how big of an area.
Oh, I mean, you know, that's, that's,
it's a generic question cause we discover
you'd have to look up the numbers,
but it's like 2000 new species
a year, right? The little stuff,
but mostly little stuff. There's
an animal discovered most recently,
there's an animal called the Salah.
It's an animal that I'm actually
working on later this year. And it is a,
an antelope,
like they call it the Asian Unicorn
because for generations people have been
talking about the Asian
Unicorn and Western worlds
like yeah, whatever, whatever,
whatever.
And then finally somebody went down
there into the Laotian mountains and,
and was like, here's a skull and here's
a skin. And they were like, Holy Shit,
this is a real thing. And this
is like in a pot, not populated,
but there's plenty of people living there.
You know what I mean? This isn't like,
this isn't like the middle of nowhere.
This is where there's villages and
tribes and people and they're like,
here's this animal, here's
the skin, here's a skull.
And since then I think one trail
camera has the photo has ever surfaced.
Like nobody's ever successfully documented
it because it's just this incredibly
elusive animal, like whether it has super
sensory organs, you know, hearing sight,
smell, whatever it is, or it's just
super low density and population. I've,
nobody really knows. But
this animal, this, this huge,
like antelope has been around forever.
People,
little tribal people have been talking
about it in like a mythological way.
The same way they would talk about
dinosaurs in the Congo and the Western
world's going, sure
buddy, whatever you say.
And then somebody finally goes down there.
Doesn't expedition just like David
did and goes, oh, turns out it's here.
Wow.
What is it about animals where we're so
fascinated by the ones that might not be
real or that might be hidden? Like
what is it about them? I mean we, we,
I mean people love to study. Giraffes
are things that are absolutely real,
but they also have an even more compelling
need to search for things that are
not quite sure that, I'm not quite sure
if they exist or not. I don't know,
man. I think it's like it's human
nature to want to know more, right?
Like we of course, like not everybody
you see a draft, you're like it's real.
I know it banked it. Right.
Some people go to the extreme,
they study every aspect of it,
but as a general populous,
I feel like once we
know something's there,
we want to know what the next thing
is. And I mean we, what do you think?
Like what, why, why is it that
we're so fast ass and it was,
I don't know the answer.
I think it's probably a side effect
of our compulsion for innovation.
Like human beings are constantly trying
to find out new secrets are and find a,
find out new discoveries and
invent new things and find,
explore new worlds.
Yep.
I mean this is just something that's
been a part of human nature forever.
This desire to improve and to go
for the fund, the next best spot,
the new thing, you know? And then I
think that also works with animals.
I think we have this desire to find
animals that we didn't know a real or
weren't sure real well knowledge
is the foundation of that right?
To go to a new planet. We have to have
the knowledge of how to get there, right,
to go to a new habitat. We have to know
what's there. And I think maybe that's,
that's kind of that deep
rooted desire is like,
we need to know about
this thing in order to,
to understand if we can innovate off.